o que nós vamos jogar o juno interessa
pra você palhaço
o ato de pessoal aqui quem fala é mudar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais de um
vídeo e o estrago já que chove sei se o
pessoal espera que os outros por sido a
família de fred zé manel antes do
playbook mary não há mais para lá
pessoal que está aqui sabe escola s
o botafago tanto da isto parece um filme
com dez marcas pretas hundred miles ba
tanto to device
como assim muito boa aqui também
não eu não sei que estou fazendo aqui
cai a já percebi é que os computadores
do tempo são os quatro equipamentos e
elétricos na ufpb o mesmo costume
interruptamente carga é que a ser isso
que estou a o benfica lá na outra
esquina o c eo v
ficam lá em cima é e silverstone só
começo da casa militar muito bizarro tá
muito bizarro a qual se desligará eu sei
pq não quero vocês né ai wei temos que
lavar as mãos nela não assumiu está
muito diferente conforme net fred está
muito idêntico mesmo em vista ter uns
câmeras têm este tipo de dispositivos
elétricos e temos que manter o sétimo
andar que só uma trovoada é só uma foca
em trovoada é vejam como um ato legal é
rápido e não consegui passar apenas uma
hora é isso escolhem hora faz freqüentes
que eu acho que é isso
o centro não você não queria lá pra
baixo eu só vi a aaa
meu aproxima rap rock era raro eu só
estava a segurar o jogo
sofia sua filha esso e tinha qualquer
coisa para fazer neste kit em que não
enxergava que o computador qualquer mas
que não encontra o computador eu não
saio de cantar eu vou lá acima de tudo
está lá em cima que deu errado pois não
funciona eo que não funciona na obra mas
como é que o computador ou outra vez
algumas vezes é só fiz gosta de por ser
em alguns sítios a prenda essas lições e
tenta e não olhar pra ela muito tempo ok
já aprendi uma coisa não se ela por ser
cor nanam aposta boa pro top tomar
cuidado quando se está a desenvolver
para os quartos porque se ela por ser e
clicar os onde ela está
basicamente estou lixado é isso que eu
vi isso aqui é só questão de outra vez
já sabe um pouquinho mais sobre a soft
né
o empreendimento nós não podemos
explicar nela quando vemos à nossa
frente que é o caso quando ela aparece
lá em cima negra e basicamente tente
fugir dela é logo fugido logo na hora
não queremos nada pra ela ok então
ficará patente então a câmera aiea que o
bebê que são os que aparecem mais rápido
na tua vida lá em cima já que a porta lá
em cima mil filmes eu escutava muito bom
porque a câmara se lá em cima tem que
aparecer aqui que não pode provar dudar
que não pode provar eu não sei também já
falaram preciso ir à frente mas eu ando
aqui não é né ai ai ai eu cozinho fechou
são 86 ainda é bastante cedo não a
primeiro tá tudo vai dar errado nisso
acho que houve um gurizinho ela não anda
anda isso ronaldo cuja luz era preciso
arranjar agora a câmara a não quebra
naves um dos vars on
ainda há vida para lá meuse dirá que
mariah carey não é por aí mas nele não
haja abusos nos jogos nos novos campi
com isso a economia brasileira vem vai
lá vai meu deus
agora preciso assim outro visto na é
muita pressão e muita pressão é enorme
já que machucam do oeste do gol
desta vez vai desta vez não consigo não
há descontrole o consumo de 40 pessoal
foi de 45 conseguir que cara querido eu
acho que não vai pegar a câmera se de um
erro na vilã eu desisto há alguma luz
agora eu vou tentar ignorar né e ver se
resulta anda lá sofia na pressos aids
formarem maldito e sinop no mar se a
pouco eu vou dormir a dinâmica
ainda bem que ela não apanhou enganemos
usar o rap mil views noivo é o high esta
[ __ ] não funciona
vamos ficar atentos agora à luz a era
usado eo andrew jackson empresa e já
está lá embaixo da cama para ver e deixa
eu ficar aqui no sporting e sossegado
a minha vida é tão bonita tão feliz que
não se quer aqui na a manivela
só vamos ficar porque o espírito e
espero que vocês tenham gostado a digam
aí como é que eu posso passar esta noite
como é que eu posso chegar isso é
história quanto mais favorito fiquem
mais aproximar a mãe